in the week of an all night intense
carpet bombardment on both jabalia
refugee camp and jabalia Al balad we
were finally able to reach inside aljun
Area the Israeli occupation Force
destroyed a large number of residential
homes dozens were killed and injured and
the paramedics were not able to come to
their rescue as the bombardment went
uninterrupted as you can see de bodies
of those killed as a result of the
artillery shelling remain lying all over
the
area four members of this family were
killed here are the bodies of the father
and the youngest girl we were sleeping
and all of a sudden we were showered
with missiles and shells we woked the
explosions to find them killed and
buried under the rubble we were trapped
in this part of the
house the ambulance and paramedics are
are still unable to reach this
neighborhood the dead bodies are still
lying here including this young
girl the scale of damage is massive in
this area as we are filming the Israel
occupation force is still firing
artillery shells all over the
place more than 25 members of my family
are buried under the ruins that's in
addition to more than 20 of my neighbors
all of them are buried under the debris
we are helpless we cannot remove these
concrete Brocks with our bare hands we
have been reeling under aerial air
strikes all night followed by a ways of
artillery shelling all my family members
were killed including my father mother
and my brothers and sisters and all
their children all were killed all
buried underneath none of them survived
a total of 50 individuals were killed
and buried under there I'm
speechless here is the dead body of a
young child it's not even his body only
body parts this young child like many
others was stor to
pieces at about 4: in the morning we
woke up to the shelling without a
warning missiles and shells fell on our
heads the roof collapsed on us this is
the five floor building of our neighbors
it was leveled and all of them were
buried under the rubble we are not able
to do anything I myself recovered five
dead bodies no one can leave or enter
the area no ambulance or civil defense
are able to come to our rescue dead
bodies are buried under the debris and
we are helpless even the injured are not
able to reach any medical help this is
unbearable as you can hear the Israeli
occupation force is targeting us with
artillery shells this area inside alju
neighborhood where we are is being
pounded injuries continue to mount with
no help on the horizon anes Al Sharif
north of Gaza
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer